I'm Mike with new way egg and also drone
deer recovery we've talked about it for
a long time that we're going to release
our own egg drone trailer and here it is
I'm super excited this thing is
basically 99% done there's only one
small thing that isn't completely done
so I'll point that out once we get up
top but we're going to start with this
it is a deck over 22t trailer built with
a 32t flight deck up top for your drone
so it's going to be absolutely the best
trailer if you're looking to do a lot of
Acres so farmers or custom applicators
that are really wanting to cover Acres
this is built to run the DJI drones the
t40s you're going to get two DJI
generators they're set up with charge
boxes up top so those have cooling
station in them as well it's got power
running up top to the top deck so you
get your uh charges done and your
batteries there and then you get power
up there as well for charging your
controllers or something like that it's
going to come with a Honda GX 160 to
pump this will basically run on idle and
have enough it'll always be circulating
it's a 2-in pump up to 200 gallons per
minute so plenty of pressure so 1,000g
clear water tank and the 175 gallon
induction tank this is where you're
going to do your chemical mixing but up
top that's where it gets good so the
flight deck up top is welded by Amish
craftsmanship it's the best stuff that
we can do in this area I'm telling you
it's strong we did not go cheap I wanted
the very best strong Top Flight Deck and
so that's what we got with this uh
Flight Deck let's hop up top and I'll
show you the super secret sauce that we
have that nobody else has right
now all right so up top what I'm super
excited about is this floor this is the
part where we're just not completely
done this floor up top will be one solid
piece currently we have a couple
different pieces but it's going to be
one solid piece in the trailers that are
being mass-produced I'm telling you guys
I did over 11,000 acres in Indiana last
year great you know this is where we
come up through when we get on the top
deck we got the railing up top here this
is the power if you want to charge your
controllers and that type of thing this
is to put an umbrella to to have some
shade you're going to get a hose rail as
well it it'll go all the way out to the
the farthest drone that's set out there
this is another cool thing that I think
I haven't seen another trailer that has
done this but we built the charge boxes
into the deck of the trailer and why we
did this is we want to be really
efficient we don't want to be carrying
batteries from the front to the back you
grab one obviously lift with your legs
come over here drop it in and you're
like within two steps from you know
being able to put your battery into your
drone that is one thing that I haven't
seen anybody else do the